اهلا بك سيده تانيا فاون اذا لا
تخلوا النقاشات في منتدى
دافوس من الحديث عما يجري من قتل للمدنيين
في غزه 100 100 يوم او اكثر من 100 يوم
الان من عمر هذه الحرب ما الذي تسجلون من
مواقف بخصوص ما
يجري
اذا سلوفينيا عبرت مرارا وتكرارا عن قلقها
حول الوضع الصعب هنا في خلال جلسات المجلس
الامن وايضا فيما يتعلق بالوضع الانساني
9000 طفل فقدوا حياتهم واكثر من 23 الف
مدني هذا امر لا يطاق هذه ارقام لا تصدق
ونحن ندعو الى وقف فوري دائم لاطلاق النار
من المهم جدا والملح ان يتم ايصال
المساعدات الانسانيه لمن
يحتاجها ليس هنالك تيار كهربائي ودواء
وماء بالتالي هذا الامر يعني ان الوضع
الصحي مروع بالتالي نحن نحاول مع المجتمع
الدولي من جهه ان نقول ان هذا خرق ل جديه
ل القانون الدولي الانساني و وقانون حقوق
الانسان وندعو كل الاطراف من اجل حمايه
هذه القوانين نحن على وعي على على معرفه
بالهجمات الارهابيه ضد المدنيين في السابع
من اكتوبر التي قامت بها حماس لكنها لا
تبرر هذا الوضع المروع الذي نشهده الان في
غزه وايضا ما يقلقنا هو ما يحصل في الضفه
الغربيه العنف الذي يقوم به المستوطنون ضد
الفلسطينيين هناك بالتالي هنالك حاجه الى
ايقاف العنف والى وقف فوري ودائم لاطلاق
النار وهنالك تبدا مفاوضات
ام وسلامه الفلسطينين والسراين من ناحيتكم
كحكه سلوفينيا سيده تانيا كيف
تتحركون
للتوصل الى ما تسعون اليه الان على وجه
تحديد وقف اطلاق النار وايصال هذه
المساعدات ما هي تلك الخطوات التي بداتم
في هذا
الاتجاه
نحن نستخدم كل منصه
وكل امكانيه مثلا في مجلس الامن
و منصات اخرى من اجل ان نؤكد على
اهميه احترام قانون الدولي الانساني
وقانون حقوق الانسان نؤكد ان هنالك خروقات
خطره لا يمكن تحمل هذا الامر نطع كل
الاطراف من اجل ان يكون هنالك وقف لاطلاق
النار وان يكون هنالك نقاشات حول حل
الدولتين وهذه هي الطريقه الوحيده للمضي
قدما ولكي نرى السلام يتحقق ونريد ان نرى
سلاما للفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين مع عيشهم
مع بعضهم والى جنب بعضهم البعض بالتالي في
سياستنا هي ركزت على تكون ملتزمه ودائمه
وتعبر عن وجهات نظره نظرنا ك عضو مسؤول في
مجلس الامن وكذلك سجلتم معارضتك لمساله
محاولات اسرائيل تهجير الفلسطينيين او
المساعي في اتجاه ذلك وتحدثهم ايضا عن نيه
سلوفينيا للانضمام الى جنوب افريقيا في
الدعوه المرفوعه ضد اسرائيل حدثينا عن هذه
الخطوات الى اين وصلت وما نوع التنسيق
ايضا الذي تجرونه
بخصوصها نحن نتابع النقاشات في القضيه
التي رفعتها دوله جنوب افريقيا امام محكمه
العدل الدوليه حاليا ليس هنالك اي اجراء
للانضمام الى اي من الاطراف لكن علينا ان
نرى ما الذي
تقرره المحكمه من اجل
ان نتعامل وكيف ستتعامل مع القضيه بعد ذلك
سنقدم حجتنا القانونيه لكي نقرر اذا ما
سننظم ام لا لكنني استطيع اقول ان
سلوفينيا في كانت الى جانب المسائله
وبالتالي
نحن مستعدون لتقديم والمساعده با
استشاراتنا القانونيه في هذه القضيه كما
حصل في قضايا اخرى في فلسطين وايضا في
قضايه قضيه اوكرانيا في حال ارتكاب فضائع
خلال الحروب